The Joe Rogan Experience it's such a
good movie thank you it's so good
because it's so like you can see how he
would be like that you could see how he
would be drawn to go back there you can
see how the pullover in the chaos of it
all and then there's a scene where he's
I believe he's in a supermarket
and it's just [ __ ] boring life is
just the mundane normal life and he just
wants to go back to war yeah
it's it and I'm like I buy it all in you
know it's like it's very rare that you
know you see him there's like no
suspension of disbelief you buy you're
watching that film and you're like whoa
like I could see well that was a big
part of what we were trying to do was to
was to
so I had been and I had been in Baghdad
as a reporter
in 2000 and for I guess and
um
I had seen some of what what's depicted
in the in the film that's why I'd
witnessed the bomb squad going out and
diffusing bombs
and then and I wrote an article about it
and then
um
the idea came along for a screenplay
I had the idea to write a screenplay put
it that way and my whole thing is over
the course of a year I didn't know how
to write a screenplay but my whole thing
is I was learning how to do it and doing
rewrites was
to try to replicate the experience that
I had that I felt when I was there
okay so to do that there was a lot of
craft and whatnot involved in how to in
in creating that that I had to learn
but it also meant breaking a lot of
rules of narrative and storytelling that
you normally would do to make a movie
effective but that in this case may
would have made it less authentic to the
experience like one for example is that
most war movies
are organized around a mission
it's like in the beginning of the movie
you're told hey this is what we got to
do and then the rest of the movie plays
out like Saving Private Ryan or what
have you
uh when I was in Baghdad one of the
things I was struck by
was the this ceaseless like hamster
wheel repetition
of
the war that it wasn't organized around
a single Mission it was
this feudal attempt to try to find all
these bombs that had been
dispersed throughout the country by the
counterinsurgency
so I couldn't organize it around a
mission I had at least in my mind to
keep it authentic I had to kind of make
the story
similar enough to the reality which was
like every day a new Mission like a kind
of you know
um
episodic structure they call it so
there are all these decisions along the
way that get made
to create that feeling that you have
where you go oh I can suspend I can
suspend my disbelief because this feels
this feels real
and
then there's the point at which
like you do all this research I did all
that research of actually going there
hanging out with these guys talking to
them witnessing what they were doing
trying to get deep inside of it learning
about IEDs and how they work and really
getting inside their mentality hanging
out with them
and then there's another point at which
you kind of put yourself into the piece
too
and it's funny that you mentioned the
scene at the end
and it's it's been really instructive to
me because uh when I was doing
screenings for the herlocker a lot of
times at the end of the screening like a
vet would come up and that scene
in the grocery store
where
Sergeant James that's the character name
was like kinda
first time back from the war
and he's
he's like overwhelmed by the
commercialism
of the supermarket and all the choices
of cereal
and it's not just that it's boring it's
that it's like
so meaningless compared to what he'd
just been doing
and he can't he can't function and
you've seen this guy operate on such a
high level for the past whatever it is
hour and a half
yeah there's a scene right there oh
you can't choose you know
all this like uh consumer [ __ ]
it was such a good representation of
what these guys have to go through but
my
and Renner is so good there too he's
amazing but that that actual thing had
happened to me
coming back
I felt this sense of dislocation and I
was only there for like a couple weeks
but I felt this sense of like how
severely
grotesque like certain parts of our
wealth our after you're in after you see
this poverty and you see the hardship of
the war
so that was like my thing that wasn't
like a research thing
and it's just interesting it was like
totally from my heart and I remember
putting it in and thinking this is one
of the rare things in the movie that
like I didn't get from
reporting
and it actually turned out to be one of
the things that translated the most to
other people and it kind of taught me
about like well sometimes if you just
dig deep enough probably there's a
chance anyway
that like your experiences or my
experiences if you're really being
honest about them and this goes back to
where we started this conversation
will translate to other people hmm
even if you don't even if you think
they're super hyper [ __ ] specific to
you
yeah does that make sense yes it might
be hyper so that's what I'm so relatable
it's relatable because it is in
retrospect but at the time I was like
this is just a weird thing that happened
to me no but you nailed it because you
because in the context of the movie you
know you see that this guy is
I mean every time he's defusing a bomb
this could be it
and he's over there in this this
chaos-ridden war zone and then he comes
back and he's wandering through a
supermarket aisle it was perfect it was
the perfect juxtaposition
and it really does you you you do relate
to it because I think all of us are
aware that
you kind of get accustomed to whatever
you're around
you know you get accustomed to a chaotic
home life or a peaceful home life you
get a very busy workplace where things
people yell on each other and
everything's constantly moving fast or
boring droning cubicle life like people
understand that there's like certain
ways of living and existing that you can
get accustomed to and they kind of make
sense when you've adjusted and adapted
to them but then
to have such a clear difference between
being in a war zone and being in a
supermarket it was it was perfect
well thanks
I'll take that yeah no it was really
good man it's like what what does it
feel like to have the responsibility of
trying to relay one of the most complex
aspects of
human life which is war
it's funny when you said perfect I just
flashed on not to not answer your
question but I remember there was some
reviewer
at the time that called it a near
Perfect movie and I remember calling him
up and being like near perfect
like is that near really necessary well
because I want to put it on the I I
wanted to put on the DVD anyway we did
we left it on there it's still I mean
you know but it's hard for someone to
say something's absolutely perfect no of
course that it's it's stupid no yeah
it's perfect but it's funny though when
you said perfect what the [ __ ] bro
you're perfect what's near yeah what
more do you want yeah no I do feel the
sense of responsibility I mean I think
that uh
I think we're all responsible I think
whether you're doing a topic like that
where I tend to do real life stuff
although the this most recent thing
is fictional I think that anybody in the
media has a huge sense of responsibility
that comes with the territory
whether they feel it or not or take it
on I don't know I think it would be nice
if we lived in a world where people felt
more responsible
because I think a lot of what is put out
there is very irresponsible
and I'm not even talking about like with
true stories of like history where
you're distorting history that's
obviously irresponsible but there's so
much
of our cultural production
the corporate production that is in my
view irresponsible
I take the responsibility seriously just
because
I know in that case there are there are
people
um
there were people that were still
downrange and In Harm's Way
so there were all kinds of things that I
did I was careful to not depict because
I didn't want to put anybody like that's
the most basic level of responsibility
right nobody should get hurt because you
burn some classified thing so like in
terms of like tactics that are used
tactics or like there was um at the time
in the war there was there was a um
there there was this like jamming system
that was you that was
um used to help
um prevent like remote detonation
of of these IEDs electronic jamming
systems
and I didn't depict that at all and then
after the movie came out a bunch of army
guys were like that wasn't realistic I'm
like yeah I mean it is super realistic
but yes I left some things out because
yeah that makes sense people called me
and they're like dude you can't put that
in that right that would be bad yeah so
there's that level of responsibility but
then there's another responsibility to
to more like mystical things like truth
and history
which I also feel pretty acutely what
when you talk about
irresponsible depictions like what what
do you mean by that
I I mean I think that like I think that
media is really important
like to our culture to our to our
civilization
and
one way to think about it is like
there's more responsibility now around
let's say portraying diversity
we've we've gotten a lot better at
at least trying to make movies and
television shows that are more
reflective of like what the country
really looks like
but there's other areas where I don't
see that same level of responsibility
one is like the obvious one that that
the right talks about all the time is
like depiction of guns and violence
where
there's just so much
and I I mean I have violence in the show
I'm not I'm not like saying like and I
and I I'm not like
anti-fire arm or anything but but but
there's so much irresponsible kind of
taking heavy [ __ ] that has real
consequences and aestheticizing it is
irresponsible to me
it's [ __ ] and
um
and per and there's that's a kind of
abuse of I think of like the
responsibility that that that comes with
the power of telling stories when you're
telling a story like in a way it's it's
a kind of like remote teaching you're
kind of putting something out in the
world and saying like this is how it is
so that's that's another one is like
plot people abuse plot all the time
which which kind of bugs me because
if I'm telling you a story and I and the
plot is so radically disconnected from
how things really work I'm not talking
about science fiction but even within
science fiction
if I pause it to you like here's here
are the set of rules of this story and
then I break them
I think that's really irresponsible
because it's [ __ ] with people's heads
it's like making them Dumber in a
certain way that I mean it would take me
a while to explain but these are the
kinds of things that I think about
sometimes no it makes sense like you're
trying to do a film that's impactful but
it's also
you it's it's easy to follow because you
understand that this is how people
behave and this is how it would really
go down so here's an example like if I
made a movie
about
Iraq
where
you ended up feeling
like really good about the war
um
like a feel-good movie about the war
yeah happens all the time yeah you know
I think that's irresponsible not that
there aren't like amazing stories of
heroism and not that there aren't
moments about that war to feel good
about but the overall gist of it is it
like was
um
a catastrophe how is it managing that
when you're dealing with Studios and
Executives and all these different
people and you know like they is it
difficult to get people on board with
what you're trying to to do you're
really trying to make it authentic and I
don't really I typically I haven't
really messed with any of that stuff
like we made those movies uh Catherine
Bingo and I made those movies like
independently oh that's nice so we had
well that makes it's like very
cowboy-ish you know I mean we had
financing from
from a whole bunch of different places
like we pre-sold the foreign rights and
this is getting inside baseball but we
never had to deal with like
a fox or a universal or a Sony
and even when we made Zero Dark Thirty
that was financed by one person Megan
Allison who just wrote a check Jesus
what a gangster
yeah
I love Megan shout out to Megan yeah
that's a crazy move how much did that
movie cost
uh
it depends how you if it depends if you
include the production budget I think
was around 40. wow million dollars and
then promotion I think she put up
another 20 something
yeah it's pretty big luckily it worked I
know I lost somebody I lost a lot of her
money on Detroit so oh did you but she
made a lot on um on Zero Dark Thirty